في وقت سابق، تحدث أليكس ماركات من CNN مع
يوسف هماش، عامل إغاثة في
المجلس النرويجي للاجئين الذي يعيش في
غزة مع عائلته، وناقشا كيف
كانت الحياة في غزة بعد ثلاثة أيام
من وقف إطلاق النار المؤقت ولماذا يشعر بأن
المجتمع الدولي بحاجة
إلى بذل المزيد من أجل  ساعدونا في إيجاد
حل دائم للأزمة
هناك عشنا هذه الأيام الثلاثة وغدا سنعيش
اليوم الرابع ولكننا نجهز أنفسنا أننا
قد نموت في الخمسين
هذا هو الوضع في جي وهذه
المرة الأولى منذ 7 أسابيع  لقد تمكنا من المشي
بأمان في الشوارع والنوم
بأمان في الشوارع دون
الشعور بأنك قد تصطدم
في أي لحظة، وهذا ما
سيجعل من الصعب حقًا على الناس
العودة إلى دائرة العنف هذه
لأنه حتى بالنسبة  منذ 3 أيام،
ذاق الناس شعور الأمان، وكان الكثير من
الناس يستغلون هذه الفرصة للوصول
إلى أشخاص آخرين متواجدين في الشمال أو
مدينة غزة للتحقق مما إذا كان منزلهم
لا يزال موجودًا أو تم تدميره،
ويستخدمه أيضًا الكثير من الأشخاص  إنها فرصة
للشعور بالحزن والأسى على
أحبائهم الذين فقدوهم بينما
لم يكن لدينا حتى الوقت للشعور بالحزن على
أحبائنا الذين فقدناهم خلال
الأسابيع السبعة من أسابيع
الجنون، ماذا فعلت خلال هذه الأسابيع
ثلاثة أيام ماذا يعني بالنسبة
لك، لذلك في أربعة أيام على الأقل
تمكنت من التواصل
مع أقاربي الذين
أصيب بعضهم أثناء القصف الآن
نحن ذاهبون إلى الشتاء وقد
جاء الشتاء والناس  غير
مستعد لأنني من
الجزء الشمالي من غزة وعندما هربت إلى
الجزء الجنوبي هربت دون أي شيء لذلك أستغلها
أيضًا كفرصة للذهاب والعثور على
الأقل على ملابس مناسبة
لأطفالي لأن الطقس
سيكون قاسيًا  وليس لدينا أي شيء، لدي
سقف أغطي به رأسي ولكن الكثير من
الناس، الآلاف من الناس ليس لديهم
هذا الخيار، لم نشاهد مطلقًا
أشخاصًا بلا مأوى في غزة في حياتنا الآن، أصبح من
الشائع حقًا رؤية الأشخاص
الذين ينامون فيها  الشوارع والناس
يبحثون فقط عن أي مكان ويعتبرونه مأوى
دون أي وسيلة
للحماية، ومع هذا
سيكون من
الصعب جدًا عليهم التعامل معه. أنا أعمل
في منظمة إنسانية وإذا
قمت بالدمج  نحن جميعا
كمنظمة إنسانية ومنظمة دولية
ووكالات ومنظمة وطنية لا
نستطيع تغطية حاجة
الناس في الجنوب وهذه
الأيام الأربعة ليست كافية وهي
مهمة مستحيلة أن نتمكن من تغطية
حاجة كل المساعدات  إن الدخول فيه قد
غيّر شيئًا ما ولكن من حيث
المقارنة بالحاجة،
لسوء الحظ، فهو لا يغطي
حجم الحاجة التي لدينا المساعدة
تغير شيئًا ما ولكن لا يمكنك ذلك، فهو
غير ملموس ولا يمكنك الشعور به
بسبب مقدار الحاجة  ضخمة